in the coming years climate change could
force hundreds of millions of people to
leave their homes one of the worst
places has already forced more than 6
000 people from their homes those in the
poorest regions of the world will be the
most affected climate change is not an
abstract notion for these islands
many of these climate migrants will
cross borders and continents but it's
anticipated the majority will move much
shorter distances and stay within their
own countries families who've lost their
homes are sleeping on the roadside
countries and governments should be
planning in advance for these mass
migrations
the problem is most aren't
a lot of communities will simply die so
why isn't the world doing enough to
prepare for climate migration and what
can be done to manage this crisis better
it is a moral obligation
[Music]
I feel like I was being separated from
where I belong
so it's just like two pieces of Velcro
you know
it doesn't sit too easy with me
so much of me is still down there on
knowledge and Charles
in the summer of 2022 Chris Brunet took
the momentous decision to leave his home
on eel de Jean Charles in Louisiana
his tribe the Biloxi chitty matcha
Choctaw Indians have lived there for
nearly 200 years
is not dead
and climate change sucks
climate change gave Chris and most of
his community no real choice but to
leave their ancestral land I really
didn't want to leave well I felt like
that the decision I had to make Chris's
former home is no longer safe for human
habitation rising sea levels mean the
island is losing land which used to be a
crucial buffer that protected the houses
from storms as that buffer disappears
the impact of hurricanes is now much
worse
whenever you look at the damage to the
island there's some people their homes
were destroyed and so they had no more
home to live in
[Music]
more than 2 000 square miles of land in
Louisiana has disappeared since the
1930s
equivalent to roughly one American
football field every hour
IL de jean-childs is at the Forefront of
this catastrophe
but in its wake could be a model for
helping people caught in a similar
predicament after life on the aisle
became untenable for residents like
Chris they asked the state of Louisiana
to help them and in a groundbreaking
policy move the federal government paid
for 37 families to relocate to new homes
40 miles away here on the new aisle
when it comes to comparing this one here
to my house that I have on the island
the house on the island is one you know
I was raised in
and so I'm used to that one and so I
know this one here is uh
totally different than what I'm you know
was used to but what is helping me with
that is that I am surrounded by the
people that were my neighbors
moving Chris's Community is one of the
first examples of a state using federal
funds to relocate victims of climate
change on Mass
this kind of planned migration is a bold
idea known as managed retreat
[Music]
what sets this idea apart from
evacuation is that managed Retreat is
planned in advance and crucially there
could be more of this type of climate
migration in future across the world it
could help poor parts of the rich world
and in particular large swathes of the
developing World those who are left
behind may be the most needy in the most
vulnerable those are the ones we're
probably going to need assistance to
move
the trouble is even in the rich world
most governments haven't got round to
making any plans to move communities
moving people is incredibly expensive
Louisiana spent nearly 50 million
dollars of federal funds to move just
100 or so people
which means poor countries are in a
really perilous position
if the planet warms between 2 and 2.5
degrees above pre-industrial levels more
and more parts of the world will become
uninhabitable and the majority of those
places will be in the developing world
estimates for the numbers of climate
migrants depend on how much global
temperatures rise
but one continent will feel the heat
more than any other here in Africa home
to many nations considered most
vulnerable to climate change
the African continent it's the continent
that will be the most impacted by the
climate crisis and the shots will affect
population in a unique way up to five
percent of Africa's population by 2050
will be forced to move purely as a
result of the climate crisis in a worst
case scenario with more than three
degrees of warming that could mean more
than 100 million people being forced to
move
[Music]
the populations of entire cities in
Africa could be at risk but right now
it's hard to imagine who would put the
resources into planning and paying for
these mass migrations in big cities
particularly such as Lagos Alexandria or
the Khan it would be very difficult to
be done and to be done properly it will
require significant resources
where and how managed Retreat should be
planned varies across the world
depending on geography and other factors
but one constant is that International
funding and assistance are needed on a
large scale
it is time for the global noise
and this would require a big change in
mindset in the rich world as the saying
goes it takes two hands to clap the
global law is the historical polluters
have a responsibility to work with this
with these specific communities and to
support and assist when it comes to
manage retreat
cost isn't the only obstacle to planning
mass migrations making long-term plans
to move entire communities doesn't have
much appeal at The Ballot Box
politicians in all countries rich and
poor tend to be more interested in
short-term election Cycles nobody wants
to move and Mayors and local authorities
in particular are reluctant to even
suggest the possibility the whole
community may have to move because of
the effects of climate change this is
politically not popular
moving any Community within a country is
a hard enough sell
but what happens when a whole country
needs to move
at least five island nations could face
partial submersion due to rising sea
levels by 2100. in the worst case it's
estimated that some 2 million people
will be affected but despite the
warnings of climate scientists planned
relocation is a possibility that the
International Community is proving slow
to face up to
it will be very sad that the
International Community
is not able to provide a solution to
these nations and to these communities
which have had no finger in the climate
crisis the climate crisis will remake
who they are where they are and how they
live
many of the disagreements about finding
a solution will be about money
but no matter who pays it's important
that the country moving can control its
own destiny you know if in fact whole
countries do have to move they should be
the ones to negotiate where and how and
under what conditions they do move for
this to happen it's best to start
discussions early as some states are
trying to do
the island of tuvalu might become one of
the first countries to lose its entire
landmass to climate change
but there's little thought being given
to where its inhabitants will go
despite their pleas growing ever more
urgent
in tuvalu we are living the realities of
climate change sea level rise we must
take bold alternative action today
[Music]
right now the focus of most governments
in the rich world is on measures which
eliminate emissions like renewable
energy
and on adaptive actions like building
flood defenses
but they should also be planning how and
where to move affected populations
when it comes to relocation it is
definitely more manageable it is cheaper
it is scope of success much higher if
you do it while in advance if you plan
it
planning ahead will save government's
money but it'll also be kinder to the
people who will have to bear the brunt
of the climate crisis management treats
should not be look at solely from the
financial point of view it is not only
about moving people from point A to
point B it
building that inner resilience
in you to be productive to continue to
be hopeful and to continue to be at
peace with itself and the climate and
the climate crisis
hello I'm Tom standage Deputy editor at
The Economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe